we certainly want to get him done uh you
know he's the
straw if you will that stirs our drink
and
uh he's a key part of what we're about
you know those things take time to get
done
that was cowboy's ceo stephen jones back
in may on the pft pm podcast at a time
when the cowboys didn't quite realize
that ezekiel was inclined to draw a line
in the sand and hold out back in may he
was participating in the off-season
program he would be there for all of the
voluntary workouts he would be there for
the mandatory mini camp they thought
nothing was amiss they thought he was
content with his spot in line chris sims
behind dak prescott and amari cooper and
lo and behold they found out in a very
harsh and dramatic way last week that
he's not okay with that and it's really
turned everything upside down for the
cowboys and they are currently not
saying he's the straw that stirs our
drink they're trying to sell the
argument chris that their drink doesn't
need a straw yeah no no i it needs a
straw and he's still the the straw that
stirs their drink you know they can say
whatever they want i get it you know
yeah i'm with you mike it seems like
they were totally caught off guard by
this they love ezekiel ella you could
tell that just by the things they said
said about him over the years the way
jerry jones gushes about him i mean and
he gave us no inkling that this was on
his radar throughout otas in the spring
either i mean it seemed like he was just
going to be the team guy and do what's
right by the jones family and do that
but i think he realized no
i got to start taking care of myself so
uh
again i know jerry jones i mean or i
want to say stephen jones made the
argument yesterday right that oh okay
we're not going to be market setters
right in the in as far as giving the top
contracts out and letting that that's
fine and dandy okay with dak prescott
and amari cooper i'm gonna echo what i
said in the first hour that's fine you
can warrant them not being market
setters they need to be paid you know
respectable for their position because
they're top end players at their
position but ezekiel elliott i mean this
just
dallas cowboys you're about to set the
market with the running back uh position
if you want ezekiel elliott back i mean
there's just no way if i'm ezekiel
elliott i don't take one penny less than
the todd gurley contract and and i don't
come back until i get more money than
that and he's earned that and and uh so
they're gonna they're gonna have to bow
to that one i think when all said and
done
and you know the battle lines really are
being drawn here ezekiel with his line
in the sand and the cowboys feel
compelled to draw their own line in the
sand because for the cowboys this isn't
just about ezekiel elliot this isn't
just about the 2019 season this is about
running a football team on a
year-to-year basis and not being
perceived by any current or future
cowboys players or their agents as a
team that will be easily pushed over
that will blink that will cough up money
for a key player they're going to stick
to their principles and that's going to
be the challenge as this thing digs in
and this is the message that came from
stephen jones yesterday in an appearance
on ktck am in dallas we can't push the
issue unless we want to be a market
setter and we're damn sure not going to
be a market setter because of all the
things that go with being a dallas
cowboy chris they are taking the concept
that they previously were applying to
dak prescott that there is inherent
value to being the cowboys quarterback
and you should take less money because
of it to ezekiel elliott and it tells me
they're going to apply it to everybody
yeah that there is a price that you pay
to have that silver helmet with the blue
star you give up salary you give up
bonus you give up money because there is
a value a cash value tangible and
intangible for you to be able to say i'm
a member of the dallas cowboys and i
don't think that's going to fly because
ultimately the people who are
negotiating these contracts do not get a
percentage of the inherent value of
being a member of the cowboys they get a
piece of whatever the contract is worth
yeah i mean yes and and again the dallas
cowboys it's a special franchise one of
the greatest sports franchises in all of
sports i get that
but that's just a crazyville you know
nobody is benefiting from the dallas
cowboys star in their helmet other than
dak prescott right now you know and
really that's only it's always going to
be the top i haven't seen ezekiel
elliott in any commercials i haven't
seen any other dallas cowboy players in
any other commercials so what are they
making whoa they must be making big
money and doing stuff that we don't even
know i mean no that doesn't exist
they're not making that much money off
the field it's special to be with the
dallas cowboys hey get that what jerry
jones is saying there i'm here steven
jones only applies to the quarterback or
maybe you know like we talked about
emmitt smith and michael irvin who were
part of like some of the greatest teams
in the history of the sport and won
three super bowls okay they've got that
but no these other guys haven't earned
that like off the field commercial you
know success yet that's not there so you
know again mike i mean to me
do you feel me with what i'm saying like
dak prescott well here's the thing
here's the thing with zeke with zeke
there's a certain six game suspension
from 2017 that may have an impact on his
ability to earn money off the field uh
yeah right you're right he's done things
yes i get that i get that right or wrong
right whatever whatever the because i
still think there are some issues with
the nfl's investigation with its
in-house justice system yes i don't
think zeke had a fair chance to defend
himself the bottom line is he got
suspended six games he was painted with
that scarlet letter of domestic violence
right he is not going to be getting
endorsement deals no matter how many
yards he rushes for and no matter what
helmet he's wearing so this idea of the
value of being a cowboy clearly doesn't
apply to ezekiel elliott no it just
doesn't he is there to run the football
move the chain score touchdowns stir the
drink and set up the rest of the offense
and they've got to pay him for it and
and this and and again i don't know how
much of this is just texas bluster and i
don't know how much of it is the actual
position that the cowboys are going to
take and we'll find out when they decide
that they're gonna go forward if they
decide to go forward in the regular
season with alfred morris or someone
else at running back instead of zeke
yeah well they're not zeke and they're
gonna be disappointed by what they see
because they're gonna get and they're
gonna watch film and they're gonna go
whoa that was a huge hole what we only
got four yards yeah that's that's called
ezekiel elliott right because yeah he
would have flown through that hole
because he's got great speed or that arm
tackle he would have ran right through
it or he would have ran over that
linebacker and got seven more yards or
whatever it may be so you know the the
the talent of ezekiel elliott they're
going to see what they're missing at
some point in time it's going to come
come to fruition now you know to me like
what what is the this is like an easy
contract to me with ezekiel when you
really look at it i mean it really is
first of all running backs aren't making
30 million dollars a year i mean todd
gurley he's the highest paid running
back in football you know what his his
cap hit is this year seven million
dollars i mean 7.2 million dollars for
the best running back in football and
for the position that you've defined
your team by by running the ball
offensive line we're gonna pound you and
beat you and just you know physically
obliterate you that way well hey if
that's the way you're built and you got
you drafted a guy at number four in the
nfl draft and he's been to study your
team you know to me oh seven eight
million dollars a year in the salary cap
hit that i mean that's nothing to pay
for this type of guy well but but now
that's the way that the gurley deal was
structured yes bigger cap hits coming in
future years
there's a way to navigate the salary cap
in a creative fashion to deal with it
and that gets to the other quote that
stephen jones had yesterday on ktck he
said we want our players to feel good
about their contracts at the same time
we don't want to do things that are out
of line because we can't afford to be
that way when we save money it's not
jerry and me saving a dollar it's just
money that's going to another player
yes but
there are ways to structure these deals
to to chew up bigger chunks of salary
cap in future years and teams can be
creative and the cap keeps going up and
it's going to keep going up and it's 180
million right now and the cowboys
according to the nfl pa website
currently have 27 million in cap space
for 2019. they can do this deal and they
can do it easily and they can back load
it if they want to and pay ezekiel
elliott here's the key and you touched
on it chris we can say well the running
back market isn't all that strong and
you know because you can find this guy
or that guy right okay fine for most
teams it's not strong because they don't
put a huge premium on the running back
right this team does in this team the
running back is critical yeah we saw
what they were in that year that they
didn't have demarco murray before
ezekiel elliott arrived it's one of the
reasons why they had the fourth pick in
the draft because they didn't have a
great running back in 2015. and so
now that you have a guy and now that
he's the straw that stirs your drink you
better pay him accordingly and you're
not going to get out of it by saying
well there's an inherent value in being
a member of the cowboys that's not going
to matter to elliot and it's definitely
not going to matter to his agent and and
really chris that's where we are right
now yeah they're they're they're doing
the the boys and girls at the middle
tool dance they're lined up on separate
sides of the wall staring at each other
and i don't see anybody moving anytime
soon and i think elliot and his camp are
content to sit and wait for the cowboys
to make the first move and the cowboys
may paint themselves into a corner with
all this tough talk because once you do
that how do you save face yeah right i
know and you know again with you know
the dallas cowboys yes they got a
talented football team and they're gonna
have guys that are gonna command big
money coming up here with you know uh
becoming free agents and wanting new
contracts i get that so they're in a
tough spot they're trying to balance it
it's a good problem to have you know it
is uh so they're going to have to deal
with that it is is it is it a good
problem to have well i don't know
it's not there they don't have a
contract with dak prescott i you know
the the challenge is once you develop
these great young players finessing
these deals in a way that gets them done
in a way that the players happy the
team's happy and they haven't been able
to do that
you know for for as great as business
people as the joneses were before they
got into football and as bad as they
were at identifying football players
it's now flipped over they've figured
out how to get the football players but
they haven't figured out how to make
them all happy with contracts yeah well
i mean it's one of the things when you
when you just accumulate you know freak
of nature studs all the time all the
time you know yeah well they're freak of
nature studs and you're gonna have to
pay them freak of nature money okay
where guys like bill belichick you know
we've seen him trade down or not go do
anything the first week of free agency
or do anything like that why because
he's gonna go okay i'm gonna find the
next level down as far as the player
save money get more players and then i
know my coaching and everything like
that will really make things a lot of
equal where maybe my talent is as good
as some of the other top end talent but
my coaching and depth and the
versatility i find in players so that's
a really hard way to do it the cowboys
go after studs and now because they got
studs they got to pay out money now you
know they're they're in a tough spot you
said it but like guys like as far as the
market setting like hey doc prescott i
would expect him to get a contract that
maybe one-ups carson wentz right just a
little bit i understand that amari
cooper i mean amari cooper doesn't
deserve to be paid like michael thomas
or odell beckham jr or anything like
that he doesn't warn that he just
deserves to be paid top 10 receiver
money if it's a great year this year
okay maybe top five receiver money but
the ezekiel elliott situation the
running back position the most physical
position in all professional sports they
can't get out of this one the the four
years 57.5 million for todd gurley that
is the minimum
for ezekiel elliott right there and they
should just get this done and get it
over with because of all the things you
said the team is built around the
running back
yeah and i agree with you completely and
the one guy who is going to be the most
nervous about this entire situation
isn't steven jones it's not jerry jones
it's jason garrett the coach of the team
who is in the last year of his contract
and he is coaching for his next contract
and he doesn't have the straw that stirs
his drink available to him he told
reporters on wednesday to be honest with
you i never really think about my
contract i never thought about that as a
player i don't think about it as a coach
i just come to work every day and try to
do the best job that i can do in the
position that i have yeah that's that's
a long way of saying serenity now by
jason garrett because how do you not
think about the future at some point how
do you not as you're going through this
year from time to time consider maybe
this is the last time i'm going to be
doing this and whether or not it is the
last time depends upon what kind of
results i can get as the coach of the
team and without ezekiel elliott there
it's going to be harder for him to get
those results
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports